hey it's gonna Elliott with blue burger
suits and we're here with the new Aston
Martin Vulcan today the Geneva Motor
Show Aston Martin unveiled the
production version of its Vulcan the car
executives are calling the most extreme
supercar Aston has ever made this Vulcan
has a v12 engine with 800 horsepower a
six-speed sequential gearbox Brembo
Racing brakes and a carbon fiber
monocoque that helps the car stay under
3000 pounds that all combines to make
the car primed for track dominance the
first thing you notice when you see it
are the huge air vents and hood and the
enormous rear spoiler there are
carbon-fiber accents throughout all the
better for making this animal as light
as possible from the rear you'll see the
crazy orange tail lights that stick out
like quills from the futuristic hedgehog
rumor has it that the Vulcan hints at
the design and performance we can expect
to see and the three new model lines
Aston will debut by 2020 as Aston head
Andy Palmer says during today's press
conference the Vulcan expresses the dark
art of Aston Martin to perfection which
as you might expect means it's only fit
to drive on a racetrack no suburban
laundering in this thing allowed only 24
of them will be made
has been Hannah Elliot with Bloomberg
masseuse we just took a look at the new
Aston Martin Vulcan